your relationship with Danny Radcliffe
is a massive part of your story how he
my boy yeah like he's one of my best
friends he still is to this day we speak
all the time and we first saw him swing
the bat and the ball up in uh orwick
castle and it's when Greg removed his
cigar out of his mouth and he said we
got some work to do with him so um
Daniel would come into the stunt
Department uh twice a week maybe three
times a week and I'd be his PE
instructor so I'd teach him gymnastics
and then we do Judo we do trampolining
jump off of portal cabins and it was an
environment that we could create for him
where he could just be a kid but also it
was a great place for Dan to develop his
physicality and for our relationship to
also develop so when I see him now in
his physicality I can vicariously live
through that brings me much joy